I'm gonna catch in my mouth seaweed
chips I just don't see how this could be
bad it doesn't need to be a chip I kind
of got an ocean eat taste to it
I felt like dried seaweed with my hands
the other day it feels like a dead
person's spear I don't hate it but I
wouldn't buy with my hard-earned cash I
love it okay that is really good I think
the flavor is so delicate I think you're
just like so wrong
salmon chip just trying to figure out
who this girl could be I find it odd
that she has a whisk
yet it's salmon and their potato chips
was officially very pretty it's very
spooky there's something sexual about
this I feel like I'm about to taste
vagina tips I'm not sure what to feel or
what to think just like a potato Eggs
Benedict
Oh tastes like Lunchables made it's like
a cheap fish it does taste like a vagina
then they nail down hot chili squid hot
chili squid hey already not excited
broccoli oh well broccoli smells like
farts and everybody knows it it kind of
tastes like anything but I can't
blabbering no but then something happens
it's not happening for you oh these are
great
yeah I could eat a bunch of it's the
boss's sign haha I was like hey here's
my new flavor and everyone's like okay
well it doesn't really taste like
anything as I gather I'm the boss's son
with the flavors lime peppers Jeezy's
lime cheese pepper shrimp chili party
platter like I'm in the wrestling arena
and it's me against four flavors lime
kicked you in the face first
woo tag-team shrimp comes out chips like
you want to mess with me it's a little
shrimpy you're knocked out at this point
you're still fighting though you cheese
sneaks up it might be some background
cheddar in there yes in background
cheddar again no no so strong
Tomek Froot Loops that's like that
mystery play whoa that's what I just
blew my mind I can't get over there with
those are fillers it doesn't have to be
a chip yeah I think that's what we
learned today could be doesn't have to
the backer covered over yeah Jesus
stooping to get a good workout and open
his bag this has no air in it so it
doesn't help create that vacuum